[Music]  just a message to the fans who are  heartbroken oh I love you guys so much  and you make it the best time in my life  I'll never forget it  only et got normani Corday breaking her  silence on a fifth Harmony's indefinite  hiatus the singer stepped out for the  boohoo block party in Hollywood  Wednesday night along with her 5h  bandmate at Dinah Jane Dinah a message  to the harmonizer sorry  [Music]  the girl group announced today would be  taking a break earlier this week in  order to focus on their solo projects no  Monty's collab with Khalid love lies is  currently blowing up the charts  [Music]  show me  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]